ça se passe en deux temps tout d'abord
dans la nuit de jeudi à vendredi vers 3h
du matin une femme qui était seule
puisque son mari travaillait elle était
seule avec sa petite fille de 6 ans donc
dans la chambre d'à côté elle est
réveillée par un bruit par du bruit elle
est réveillée également par une odeur de
transpiration qu'il a des qui la dérange
quelque chose d'assez fort et le bruit
provient de la chambre de sa fille elle
va dans la chambre de sa fille et tombe
nez à nez avec un individu
elle est pétrifiée elle se met à hurler
l'individu prend la fuite elle appelle
son mari le mari arrive il dépose
plainte le lendemain au commissariat
donc nous sommes à Roanne dans un
quartier le quartier du mayolet
et le père de cette petite fille décide
avec des amis
trois amis très exactement
de faire non pas une milice mais de
d'exercer surveillance de rechercher
l'individu que la mère de l'enfant a
parfaitement bien vu il y a un moment où
ils sont face à face et elle a quelques
centimètres d'elle et donc elle en fait
une description extrêmement précise un
des voisins et amis du du père de cet
enfant dit qu'il a vu un type qui
correspondrait au signalement rodé
depuis quelques jours dans le quartier
etc bref ils exercent leur surveillance
et dans la soirée donc dans la même dans
la même dans la soirée dans la foulée
l'agression c'est dans la nuit de jeudi
à vendredi et dans la nuit de vendredi à
samedi les copains et le papa de cette
jeune fille de cette petite fille
exerce une surveillance donc la famille
n'a pas porté plainte le lendemain
a priori ils ont porté plainte au
lendemain matin le lendemain matin donc
avant d'aller vendre
donc là dans la nuit de vendredi donc là
il recherche
il recherche un agenda donc ils ont
signalement exactement et donc un des
copains avec cru d'avoir croisé bureau
des dans le dans le quartier
et là noir c'est complètement
surréaliste parce que c'est quand même
rare qu'un qu'un j'allais dire un
criminel c'est pas un crime mais c'est
une un délit mais que que le délinquant
revienne le lendemain sur les lieux de
son forfait et là il se passe un truc
incroyable c'est que il voit
un individu qui correspond à leur
signalement en train d'escalader le même
grillage le même
et là bon il y en a un qui l'arrête et
c'est un gamin de 16 ans il le plaque au
sol ils le prennent en photo pour
présenter la photo à la maman qui est la
seule dans l'histoire à avoir vu
physiquement
l'agresseur la mère confirme qu'il
s'agit bien de cet individu et à partir
de là ça dérape ça dérape
en tout cas le père c'est usage de
d'armes par destination comme on dit
c'est-à-dire c'est pas une arme c'est
pas un revolver ou un couteau c'est une
barre de fer et il lui flanque une
flanque une bonne raclée ils appellent
la police en même temps ça c'est la
seule bonne idée de ce moment-là la
police arrive mais siffle
l'arrêt de des violences
il est hospitalisé la vie enfin le la
victime on est perdu mais la graisseur
est hospitalisée il y aura 10 jours
d'été bon pas grand chose et placer en
garde à vue il a il devait donc bien
voir quand même des éléments qui ont
permis à la justice de le mettre en
examen et de l'incarrer quel est le
profil du de l'agresseur
il a 16 ans c'est un guinéen et il était
arrivé en France depuis 15 jours en
situation a priori totalement
irrégulière
à côté il y avait peut-être été repéré
et en fait il a été incarcéré parce que
le juge a considéré que comme il n'avait
pas d'attache qu'il était perdu si tient
sur irrégulière il y avait un risque de
fuite donc c'est pour ça qu'ils l'ont
mis en prison c'est pour ça
totalement d'accord et la maman est sûre
d'elle la maman est sur d'elle et je
pense honnêtement que s'ils l'ont
incarcéré en plus des raisons viennent
de donner Gilles c'est qu'ils ont des
éléments qui leur permettent de le faire
et puis l'ont vu et ce qu'elle a dit le
muret aussi voilà alors attention à
l'intérieur il y a des empreintes
digitales il y a de l'ADN sur ça ça va
finir par parler
et on verra comment va comment va la
petite fille aujourd'hui parce qu'on
pense à elle avant qu'on avant qu'on en
parle avec boule Anouar moulin noir vous
avez des nouvelles la petite fille non
parce que c'est voilà
pas de nouvelles non la mer le père elle
est elle est dans quel
ça doit être très difficile pour elle
c'est compliqué c'est compliqué dans le
sens où même chez vous vous êtes en
sécurité totale
c'est chaud en fait
c'est chaud en fait alors moulin noir
merci d'être avec nous on aimerait que
vous nous racontiez vous vous étiez
voilà au cœur de l'affaire donc vous
vous habitez à côté de en fait j'habite
en face d'accord vraiment sur la gauche
et là c'est vous vous aviez vu quelque
chose de de suspense
au quartier
croiser un peu les copains les amis vous
disent voilà ce qui s'est passé voilà ce
qui s'est passé déjà
c'est pas comme si on vous racontez que
déjà c'est horrible c'est pas quelque
chose de classique
des parents on a souvent tendance à se
dire que ça arrive aux autres ça arrive
pas chez nous en fait mais c'est ça en
fait le problème le vrai problème dans
l'histoire c'est ça en fait c'est que il
y a personne qui veille sur personne
chacun tout le monde illégocentré c'est
chacun sa excusez-moi de le dire comme
ça mais c'est chacun tout ce que vous
voulez chacun son chacun en fait pas aux
autres après voilà alors qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé vous arrivez au quartier les
gens vous raconte l'histoire vous
connaissiez le papa bien sûr c'est mon
ami d'enfance votre ami d'enfance donc
là vous allez le voir bah ouais logique
je veux le voir
parce que le papa il devait être dans
une dans une rage je dis pas grand chose
je veux être honnête avec vous dis pas
grand-chose les discussions c'est même
pas des discussions en fait c'est
[Musique]
c'est voilà c'est quelques mots c'est
quelques bribes où est-ce que je veux
dire est-ce qu'il vous a dit un moment à
quel moment il vous a dit demain soir je
veux qu'on veut qu'on aille chercher
c'est indépendance c'est moi-même c'est
vous-même il se passe un truc de malade
à 10 mètres de chez moi
j'étais pas rangé une sœur je suis
famille bien sûr des gens qui comptent
pour moi mais même même la petite elle
compte pour tout le monde normalement
c'est pour ça que j'ai commencé par dire
si tout le monde veillait un minimum sur
tout le monde bah ce genre de situation
déjà il y en a pas mal qui se réunit les
je pense je pense que déjà ça aide enfin
je sais pas moulin noir juste pour
revenir sur sur les faits et c'est vrai
que ce que vous dites c'est très
intéressant et c'est important de le
dire ce soir juste c'est vous qui
retrouvait le
présumé coupable effectivement en fait
comme je vous ai dit j'ai pris la
décision depuis 23h30 la nuit de vous je
vais le chercher
de vendredi samedi voilà je vais le
chercher ouais mais voilà comment vous
trouvez quoi vous êtes dit je vais
essayer de retrouver après je me dis
quoi je me dis le mec il est venu hier
quand ça l'a cherché il a disparu en a
rien de temps donc ça veut dire qu'il
est pas loin pour moi voilà il faut pas
être sorti
à terre à proximité bien je sais pas il
a un endroit où se retrancher donc vous
y allez demain je me dicte peut-être que
dans les mêmes conditions ça reste
hypothétique vous êtes tout seul quand
vous le cherchez moi de mon côté ouais
je suis tout seul tout seul
à 35 mètres de chez mon ami via laquelle
heure 23h30 non depuis 23h30 je tournais
je suis allé à 2h30 2h 2h30 je suis plus
exactement le matin d'accord voilà je me
gare je me pose il s'est passé quoi une
quinzaine de minutes c'est fou
c'est incroyable incroyable
c'est un truc de malade mental c'est la
15 minutes et là vous voyez
et là en fait j'écoute un bruit de
claquettes au sol comme du gravier il
est 2h30 du matin l'éclairage public est
l'état bien sûr
je suis totalement noir tu as pas de
club dans les mains tu as pas ton
téléphone dans les mains
après le plus grand regret que j'ai
comme je disais c'est que je l'ai vu
tout seul en fait
ça c'est un truc ça me rend malade
pourquoi pourquoi parce que seul notre
voix elle vaut rien malheureusement
c'est la vérité il faut être concret
faut arrêter de se voiler la face elle
vaut rien par contre s'il y aurait
plusieurs personnes tu aurais vu ce que
moi j'ai vu à ce moment-là qu'est-ce que
vous avez vu à ce moment-là cette
grimper le lit
24 heures après à 20 minutes près
détente sur la même maison mais bien sûr
il est en train de regrimper le grillage
sur la même pour aller dans la même
maison oui dans la même maison de là où
il est parti la veille de là où personne
l'attraper donc après moi je suis pas
expert à la matière donc là vous le
voyez il se passe dans sa tête mais je
me dis peut-être que le mec il a un
sentiment de puissance totale il se dit
moi
je sais pas ce qui se dit dans sa tête
et là vous faites quoi vous faites quoi
à ce moment-là
au début je regarde j'attends j'écoutais
le bruit de claquettes comme je vous
l'ai dit j'ai regardé le rétro je vois
le mec il commence à vouloir escalader
il y a deux options qui s'offrent à moi
soit je le laisse rentrer
je sais pas moi ce qui va se passer à
l'intérieur moi personnellement et je
pense comme beaucoup de gens il a été là
de façon là quelqu'un est rentré chez
toi le lendemain
correspond à la fin bref il se passe le
papa et la maman était là il était allé
travailler
tous ensemble dans le salon
dans le salon donc lui il a les
retourner il allait retourner récidive
donc là vous avez dit il y a deux
solutions ou bien je te laisse rentrer
là vous dites ça va être un drame
je vais m'en vouloir ravi pourquoi vous
pensez quoi comment pourquoi vous vous
dites quoi vous dites
vous êtes chez vous je peux désolé
je vous prends dans un contexte vous
avez même pas vécu ça la veille c'est
même pas vous avez même pas avec ça
c'est bon ils ont vécu ça la veille déjà
il faut le dire voilà ok
ils sont en état de choc
rentre chez vous je vous la fait bref
vous allez faire quoi sans rentrer dans
le détail vous allez faire quoi vous
allez vous défendre votre famille non
mais surtout en sachant ce qui s'est
passé la veille encore plus donc
bien sûr en fait c'est dans le monde il
y a une logique qui régit le monde et si
on respecte pas cette logique
un problème si on admet pas quelque
chose d'évident c'est qu'on se voit la
face alors parce que il y a des gens qui
vont vous dire aussi important de dire
on va appeler la police on va voir on va
essayer
voilà je sais non mais voilà si
quelqu'un s'introduit chez vous on va
appeler police on va essayer mais c'est
vrai que voilà là vous êtes surpris là
il y a la veille la veille il s'est
passé ça donc vous vous dites dans votre
tête je vais pas faire un cadeau à mon
ami et je vais le regretter toute ma vie
évidemment je veux pas faire un cadeau à
mon ami qui va gagner dans l'histoire
bien sûr si le mec qui met des coups de
couteau au gars qui va gagner lui il va
se manger des coups de couteau dans
l'histoire mon pote il va faire de la
prison la femme à mon pote le
traumatisme il va être décuplé bien sûr
du fait que son mari tombe en prison
parce qu'il l'a défendu imaginez un jour
après que sa fille agresser parce que
papa défendu sa fille ben je sais pas à
un moment donné il faut se mettre dans
le contexte après
alors donc là vous décidez vous aviez
deux solutions donc la première ou la
deuxième solution c'est de quoi c'est
d'intervenir tout de suite donc vous
avez fait quoi
d'ailleurs je sais même pas comment j'ai
fait je préfère être c'est vrai c'est
fou qu'est-ce que vous avez fait je suis
allé vers lui je suis resté une dizaine
de minutes en face à face avec lui dans
le noir total vous avez parlé ouais
j'essaie de le questionner j'essaie de
comprendre qu'est-ce qui faisait là
c'est au départ
il répond pas moi je commence à
accélérer le pas vers nous je commence à
le bloquer logique je dis tu es qui tu
fais quoi
je comprends pas vous m'interpellez dans
le noir je dis bah figure-toi je
comprends pas ce que tu fais dans le
noir
vous voyez c'est je sais pas moi je
serai pas là s'il y a pas un barjotière
qui serait pas venu et j'ai d'autres
chats
c'est un peu compliqué comme au moment
je vous le dis il faut le vivre bien sûr
un truc de Barchon vous a dit quoi
je lui dis tu sors d'où il me dit je
viens de chez ma copine une soi-disant
Clara qui est inexistante pour le pour
le coup mais bon tranquille une
soi-disante clarent il m'indique à
droite il me dit il vient de là-bas ok
je veux bien il y a pas de problème je
t'accorde malgré que je t'ai je t'ai je
t'ai pris en flagrance mais ça concerne
que moi mes yeux ma parole donc mon moi
et moi donc je peux on va mettre ça de
côté je vais t'accorder le bénéfice du
doute d'accord le mec il me dit là-bas
il vient de chez sa copine une copine
il a rien ta copine tu l'appelles
comment tu la siffles
il me dit j'habite derrière dans le
bâtiment derrière et je lui dis là tu
fais quoi il me dit je rentre chez moi
ah ouais donc ta copine elle habite là
frérot toi tu habites là excusez-moi je
m'appelle
et là je te pète ici je rentre comment
chez ta copine toi
tu rentres comment chez ta copine le mec
il venait d'en bas il venait de la pente
d'en bas il était au coin de chez mon
pote tu comment tu rentres chez ta
copine et quand je l'ai interpellé il
est pas parti direction ni chez ça soit
disant de copine ni chez lui il est
parti à gauche rien à voir d'accord et
donc là vous lui dites quoi vous lui
dites et c'est toi qui était venu hier
en fait je l'ai bombardé de questions je
suis parti dans tous les sens tu fais
quoi dans la vie tu viens d'où tu as
quel âge ça fait combien de temps tu es
là tu habites où j'ai essayé de la
républer et vous a répondu des fois il
répondait des fois il répondait pas des
fois il rit donc là il voulait il
voulait pas partir un moment il a pas
voulu essayer de partir
je vais pas le laisser partir c'est
évident que je veux pas le laisser
partir
moi je fais quoi entre temps et envoyer
un message à mon pote je lui dis ça
tranquille prends une photo
on va voir ta femme c'est chaud mais va
voir ta femme vois ce qu'il en est donc
là même si je l'ai en flagrant là il est
quelle heure là il est 2h30 du matin
il est réveillé il arrive tout de suite
bien sûr il peut pas dormir bien sûr
c'est logique et donc là il sort et
ouais donc là il sort il vient il prend
la photo qu'est-ce que vous lui dites
pour prendre une photo vous lui dites
quoi
si c'est pas toi qui rentrait voler dans
la maison j'ai inventé une station
cambriolage et je lui indiquer un lieu
rien à voir et vu qu'on était dans le
noir total il voyait pas mon pote il
rentre dans quelle maison d'accord
le mec
mon pote il part il amène la photo à sa
femme le problème c'est quand il est
revenu au lieu de garder son sang-froid
tout pépère et tout arrive à 4-5 mètres
de lui il m'a dit c'est lui
donc là il est arrivé il a gueulé c'est
lui quoi il a dit c'est lui le mec il
est parti comme un V12 c'est bon pas
c'est que la quête elles ont volé en
l'air donc c'est bon pas il est parti il
a d'étaler donc là tellement j'ai honte
de le dire il pouvait plus vite que moi
c'est un truc de fou et donc après mon
pote vu qu'il court vite il l'a pris un
verre un truc mon pote qui l'a pris à
travers c'est le père de la victime
forcément le temps que j'arrive me vers
eux
je sais pas
moi j'arrive
j'essaie de contenir tout le monde mais
là quand vous arrivez il est comment le
Père mon pote il était intriqué
par terre moi je viens j'ai mobilise le
mec
j'essaie de retenir mon pote aussi en
fait c'est carrément compliqué parce
qu'il faut garder le mec avec moi il
faut que je bloque mon pote essayer de
lui faire comprendre le canaliser lui
dit c'est compliqué déjà moi-même bien
sûr c'est tendu même vous vous aviez les
nerfs
c'est moi qui l'ai vu bien sûr la grande
c'est pas quelqu'un d'autre c'est moi
qui l'ai vu en flagrance votre pote
quand il voit l'agresseur de sa fille
c'est un peu en plus il doit il sauve
donc il doit se mourir pour aller le
rattraper on imagine qu'il est dans une
colère folle normal ça on peut pas le on
peut pas on est 24 heures après le mec
il revient
enfin et donc là il disait quoi le
l'agresseur
agresseur après vous donner des détails
de ce qui pouvait lire ou de qui que qui
que ce soit pouvait dire je vais pas
vous inventer de salade d'accord ça sert
à rien c'était le je peux me permettre
le bordel c'est bon tous les deux après
on était tous les deux c'est pour ça que
ça me fait marrer quand j'écoute c'est
ça
on a dit que vous étiez trois qu'il
avait qu'il avait préparé une sorte de
mini je sais pas quoi pas du tout après
après tout le monde tournait un peu dans
son côté j'imagine bien tu es voilà
c'est pas du tout
ce qui me concerne moi je veux pas je
veux pas vous raconter quelque chose
dont je n'ai pas connaissance ou quelque
chose que je ne sais pas j'ai pas vécu
moi je vais vous dire ce que j'ai vécu
je vais vous dire ce qu'il en est je
vais vous dire ce qu'il en a été le
lendemain présence et ça donc là comment
ça s'est déroulé après il y a un pote à
moi il est sorti il m'aide à canaliser à
Nice voilà on a réussi à le canaliser
après voilà il était dans une rage folle
que il faisait que tourner pour essayer
de le faire c'est logique c'est
ça appelle la police on décide d'appeler
la police
je sais pas si vous vous rendez compte
mais c'est quand même
parce que ça les gens ils ne disent pas
c'est pas moi j'ai parlé avec la police
pour leur dire de venir c'est pas mon
pote amine qui a pas la police pour
sortir c'est anis c'est Annie ce qui a
parlé à la police pour leur dire devenir
c'est qui donc c'est bon maintenant
c'est le père donc c'est le père bien
sûr
j'ai retrouvé l'agresseur de ma fille si
vous venez pas ça va ça va partir mal
oui ils sont venus vite
après je préfère pas m'exprimer là
dessus non mais ils sont venus assez
rapidement voilà sont venus ils sont
venus c'est ce qui compte donc là
pendant tout le temps où la police doit
arriver vous essayez de contenir un peu
tout le monde on essaie de faire du
mieux qu'on peut en fait je suis ni
partie des forces de l'ordre je fais ni
partie d'un soi-disant commande et je
suis une personne simple comme vous
n'importe qui ici
directement je suis concerné ce qui
s'est passé chez lui il peut se passer
chez moi il peut se passer chez vous on
peut se passer quand on part on parle
d'une agression on dit que le papa avait
une barre de fer ça c'est faux aussi
c'est faux ça aussi on dit qu'il avait
une barre de fer c'est ce que c'est ce
qu'on dit c'est faux
moi je veux vous dire ce que j'ai vu ce
que je sais moi non mais c'est vous qui
était le principal témoin
ça a tapé avec peut-être un truc mais il
y avait pas de barre de fer faut arrêter
un truc pardon c'est quoi un truc dans
les jambes d'accord
sur la partie qui encaissent le plus le
coup donc là où il y a de moins de
chance que son intégrité physique elle
puisse être vraiment vraiment dommage et
je pense que penser à ce genre de choses
avec tout le respect que je vous dois
dans ce genre de situation
je suis personne mon ami mais c'est pas
donné à tout le monde
après je dis ça comme ça type
d'information boulet noir la police
arrive au bout de combien de temps vous
pouvez nous dire au moins ça une
vingtaine de minutes quinzaine
pour de rester dans cette situation là
donc on va essayer des minutes les plus
longues de votre vie c'est compliqué
franchement c'est franchement
franchement ça dépend de penser qu'un
jour je voudrais ça c'est un truc de
barjot donc là quoi ça crie donc de tous
les dans tous les côtes de tous les
côtés forcément il y en a ils insultes
enfin après vous connaissez le
comment ça se passe il y a des insultes
où il y a tout il y a des nerfs il y a
des tensions de péripleurs c'est
un truc de fou en fait plus personne
comprend rien
c'est c'est le bordel donc la police
arrive qu'est-ce qui se passe après la
police arrive
il est parti sur ces deux jambes
ah si tranquille on avait eu 10 jours
voilà 10 jours
et donc là il y en a pour des lynchage
pour moi que ça ils
sont toujours dans le coma
aujourd'hui ce que vous avez peur pour
votre pote qui soit poursuivi et
peut-être incarcéré
mais c'est normal moi lundi j'étais au
commissariat donc en gros moi et mon
pote il veut laisser de me coller un
soi-disant violent son Réunion c'est ce
que j'en passe c'est ce qu'on lit
exactement pas de problème donc
maintenant je vais vous dire autre chose
ça peut encourir jusqu'à 50 prisons pour
un père qui défend sa famille
et un mec qui soit disant à 16 ans il a
pas 16 ans et je suis pas au PG je suis
pas qualifié et je suis assez je pense
que je suis assez physionomiste pour
reconnaître un mec de 16 ans d'un mec
d'une vingtaine d'années tu as vu au
bout d'un moment c'est compliqué le mec
bien sûr dans ce papier là saison sinon
il va finir où rétention contrôle
judiciaire
pardon contrôle de centre de rétention
plutôt
à qui aujourd'hui la vérité
je sais pas en fait je sais pas qui en
vouloir vous voulez en vouloir écrire en
fait
c'est ça le problème parce qu'en fait
moi je suis pas dans un délire d'en
vouloir bien sûr de pas en vouloir j'ai
pas le temps pour ces conneries j'ai pas
le temps
mais je suis obligé de dire la vérité en
fait au bout d'un moment moi j'ai pas le
temps pour ce genre de chose comme tout
le monde on fait notre vie vous avez
peur votre peau votre pote vous avez pas
eu peur pour mon pote traumatisé pour sa
femme s'il prend une peine au moment
donné on met des 5 ans des gens qui
défendent leur femme à sa femme on met
des je sais pas combien des gens qui
font si ou ça des violeurs des choses
inconcevables inimaginable c'est hors du
commun
moi j'espère que au gré de l'enquête
j'espère que il va être reconnu coupable
le mec qui a fait ça de 16 ans qu'il a
reconnu là et j'espère que le père
n'aura rien ben moi aussi j'espère
qu'ils vont dire
maintenant on sait que c'est lui
c'est inadmissible
jeune homme ce mec là
à titre d'exemple la justice ne peut pas
accepter que des des gens autres des
enquêteurs puissent faire leur boulot et
ça ils vont pas l'accepter et par
principe je dis pas qu'ils vont lui
mettre 5 ans évidemment ah non il ira
évidemment pas en prison non il y aura
pas en plus il aura une peine symbolique
pour que ça ne se reproduit pas que ça
serve d'exemple et qu'on dise la justice
c'est la justice qu'il a fait et c'est
pas les c'est pas les gens après c'est
compréhensible
mais ce qui voudrait la police ce qu'il
est en train de dire jusqu'à un moment
donné il y a un excuse-moi il y a un
décalage il y a un débordement il y a un
décalage entre les peines voilà je le
contrôle parfaitement le débordement
évidemment bien sûr presque comprendre
une personne en France ou même dans le
monde entier qui va dire bah oui non on
rentre chez moi on violemment on agresse
ma fille tout va bien j'en veux à
personne c'est impossible et si on a
parce que là il y a quand même un
concours de circonstances absolument
incroyable c'est que l'auteur revienne
sur les lieux son forfait le lendemain
quasiment dans la même heure c'est un
truc de fou c'est un truc merci Michel
Marie je voudrais vous remercier boulot
d'avoir été là vous avez un témoignage
très fort merci beaucoup merci vraiment
merci beaucoup